joe i'm going to pull you in okay so you
got a question about
uh random question how do you tell a
woman that you're a virgin i know roller
says not to reveal your notch count but
i'm late to the game
does that change things of 26 so
yeah like you got a
chick in mind you're seeing somebody
like what's the deal here
yeah i've been slowly improving and i've
been talking to women and a few women
have spoken to
i eventually told them i would i'd never
been with a woman and that killed
everything and i'm
yeah that's like so
women don't care about your struggles
they hang out with the finish line to
pick the winner right so you don't want
to tell her that you're a virgin you
don't want to tell her you don't have
any experience at it
um
everybody's got a poppy it's never been
right away it's always been
friendship has developed and then
eventually
i feel like i need to tell them because
they're expecting things to get more
intimate and
how do you deal with that do you just
you don't need to tell them why don't
you tell them that you're a virgin like
how do you how do you explain like you
don't tell them you're not trying to get
outside you're not going to tell
yourself
you just have to tackle it head-on man
of course you're going to have some
performance anxiety it's the first time
right what do i do where does it go is
it going to work
it's like you know as long as she digs
your vibe right
as long as she's attracted to you it
doesn't matter of course you can have
anxiety people still have anxiety into
their 20s 30s and 40s man
you know for some guys it never goes
away
you're always going to have some of that
so
you know one time i was talking to sean
about
anxiety because i think that's one of
the areas that he specialized in so if
you don't know who sean is we did this
before the train wreck series he was he
was a he's a clinical psychologist we
were talking
shows very very early early on he was
talking about anxiety he's like you know
how do you deal with anxiety it's like
if you're if you're anxious about
riding in elevators
then you approach it from a logical calm
perspective about what it is and you
just begin to start riding elevators
sort of thing same thing with women you
know in dating and intimacy like you
know if you're anxious about what that's
going to look like you just
calmly approach it from a logical like
this is not going to be the one and only
time there's going to be
hundreds of thousands of of times where
you're going to get into it
right all you're going to do is watch
one of terence pop's older videos where
he talks about
you know his like pump count it's like
you know somebody that gets divorced and
they get taken for 20 million dollars
and he you know divides it by the number
of pumps and you know delays and all
that sort of thing like there's a big
number that comes out of it
it's it's gonna happen and you have to
be okay with it happening and you're
gonna have to be okay with a little bit
of anxiety around it's like whatever man
it's like anything else the first time
you took your first math test the first
time you got on a school bus to go to
elementary school the first time you
took your driver's license test the
first time you go right down the list
right there's a first time for
everything
you're not going to do it great you're
just going to get on with it and do it
right
and not
hold yourself yeah and not and not beat
yourself up too
too badly about it because at the end of
the day it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter it really doesn't matter to be
honest with you i bet guys in the
comments right now how many of you
got moff get jaron got skyler got all
these guys in the chat how many of you
guys
can can honestly say that
you
can remember any of the anxiety you had
or still bothers you or you're still
hung up on it to this day i mean you've
probably forgotten about it completely
i can i can go back and think
i think i was like 19. i was definitely
about 19.
right you know when i pop the cherry and
it's like
was i anxious at the time absolutely do
i remember any of it is it hung up on me
do i really care about it today it's
long forgotten
yeah look
give it a good giggle long forgotten
it's a joke it's like a stand-up comedy
you know you go watch the show you have
a laugh you get over it you go home you
forget about it
you'll be all right
okay thanks all right
you